el sistema reproductor femenino incluye
la vagina
el cuello uterino
el útero
las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios
durante el sexo vaginal entre un hombre
y una mujer el semen sale del pene del
hombre y entra en la vagina de la mujer
mediante un proceso denominado
eyaculación
el semen contiene decenas de millones de
espermatozoides
en la vagina los espermatozoides pueden
pasar a través del cuello uterino del
útero y de las trompas de falopio para
fertilizar un óvulo del cuerpo de la
mujer
la fertilización del óvulo representa el
inicio del desarrollo del ser humano
una esponja anticonceptiva es un método
temporal para evitar que las mujeres
queden embarazadas también conocido como
control de natalidad o anticoncepción la
esponja está hecha de una espuma suave
tiene una hendidura en uno de los lados
y un corto bucle de algodón adherido
evita el embarazo de dos maneras primero
la esponja cubre el cuello uterino de la
mujer para evitar que los
espermatozoides en el semen del hombre
entren en el útero
en segundo lugar contiene una sustancia
denominada espermicida que mata a los
espermatozoides
las esponjas anticonceptivas están
ampliamente disponibles en una receta
para utilizar una esponja lávese las
manos
y retírela del paquete
moje la completamente con agua limpia
apriete la esponja mojada algunas veces
para activar les permitirá que se
encuentra en el interior
luego sostenga la con el lado de la
hendidura orientado hacia arriba y doble
la esponja hacia arriba
con el bucle colgando coloque la esponja
doblada en la vagina
empuje lo más lejos que pueda dentro de
la vagina con uno o dos dedos
cuando suelte la esponja se desplegará y
cubrirá el cuello uterino
revise con el dedo para constatar que la
esponja cubre completamente el cuello
uterino y que el bucle cuelga en la
vagina
una mujer puede tener relaciones
sexuales de inmediato o hasta 24 horas
después de la colocación de la esponja
no deje la esponja colocada durante más
de 30 horas
para retirarla introduzca un dedo en la
vagina para buscar el bucle de la
esponja
engancha un dedo en el bucle y tire
lenta y suavemente
después de retirar la esponja arroje la
a la basura
una esponja anticonceptiva tiene una
eficacia del 90 por ciento para evitar
un embarazo si una mujer la utiliza
correctamente todas las veces que tiene
relaciones sexuales
esto significa que aproximadamente 10 de
cada 100 mujeres quedarán embarazadas
cada año las esponjas tienen una
eficacia de alrededor de un 85% cuando
se utilizan de forma habitual lo que
implica que aproximadamente 15 de cada
100 mujeres quedarán embarazadas si no
las utilizan siempre o si no las
utilizan correctamente cada vez que
tienen relaciones sexuales
el uso de la esponja no protege a la
pareja sexual contra enfermedades de
transmisión sexual
incluido el vih